uh it's one of these things where like i
actually don't think it's a
company-specific thing i think it's an
individual specific thing
so some people like really don't mind it
at all they actually enjoy it they want
the freedom they you know they want kind
of all these things and other people
like i absolutely hate working remotely
like i want to go do you know go into an
office i want to be around people i want
to like
you know sit at a conference room table
like all that kind of stuff and so to me
it's like less about like
is the company going to be successful or
not or can they be successful like again
yes of course they can be right but it's
just like who are the people i guess
yeah that makes sense i think two things
i think people are missing the big story
about this remote stuff
uh so what most people are thinking
about at least people i see kind of on
twitter and whatnot
is like oh how is my job going to work
am i going to be remote am i going to
go into these like little co-working
pods are we going to is our office going
to open back up
and they think like that's the extent of
the change that's happening but what's
actually
happening is is actually in some ways
much more scary for that person which is
um i like i live in silicon valley right
uh people here are divas uh they're like
you know making a ton of money and
unsatisfied the whole time
and like expenses are really high and
all this stuff and what's gonna happen
is when you're remote
you don't have to pay silicon valley
prices for talent anymore so it's not
gonna be
your the problem you're gonna have isn't
do i prefer working out in my kitchen or
do i wanna come in three days a week or
two days a week or five days a week to
the office it's gonna be
holy [ __ ] they just found somebody in
canada that's gonna work for a third of
my price
and so most people are gonna you know
when the talent pool opens up to global
because
the default work system is remote either
remote only or remote friendly
then people who are you know you really
have to be a 10xer to get paid like a
10xer
and most people think they're a 10xer
because they're getting paid like it
today but that's just because they
happen to be
you know an engineer designer pm that
lives in you know the bay area or new
york
and that's why you're getting paid these
like you know high wages
but if i can if if you're sitting on
zoom and so is some guy in pittsburgh or
czechoslovakia um yes sorry you're not
going to be making you know half a
million bucks a year anymore
because i don't have to pay that anymore
i'm getting the same output or better um
for somebody you know a faceless you
know output person
just think about it like they're just
going to measure output per zoom
endpoint
and um you know that's going to have you
know they're going to pay 80 grand for
it or 100
for it so i think companies are the ones
who win big in the end with this
and not so much the individual um
employee
well it's companies and then it's also
people who are potential employees but
don't currently work at the company
right so if you exactly
anywhere internationally for sure a huge
win um and then even
here in the united states if you're in
the midwest in certain areas right now
all of a sudden you've got much more
opportunity and you probably actually
get paid
a premium on what you would get paid
locally uh which is still a
significant decrease in cost for the
company that was exactly
it's a win-win right company gets at a
half the price and i get double my local
wage
so they're happy and so there's that
phrase like talent is universal but
opportunity is not or something like
that
um that's what's that's what's going to
happen the talent that is already
universally distributed
um is now going to receive a larger
share of opportunity to earn and prove
themselves
than is happening today same thing's
going to happen on the funding side
where
cool if i'm doing all my funding over
zoom anyways and i don't just fund bay
area companies i'm going to fund
companies everywhere
so more people get opportunity do you
think that there ends up being these
like
pods or uh remote workspaces
probably but i don't think it's that big
of a thing
so like um maybe i'm just skewed because
i like just being on my own
in fact i just consider myself like a
solopreneur now i don't want it i don't
want any employees i just want to build
my own business and run it with just me
and maybe one sidekick
uh you know who i talk to online um
but yeah i think people will have
co-working spaces because not
everybody's house is like kind of suited
for it and
companies will need to make concessions
and say cool you can go get this space
kind of you know we have we have spaces
in every city center that you can go
work at
and it's co-working like wework or regis
or whatever
um but i don't think it's like what the
quest i saw the question on twitter and
who's like
are groups of kind of friends from
different companies gonna like form
their own little co-office it's like
yeah well like
in the sitcom friends that will happen
where like you know they meet at the
perk every day at 3 p.m
and like you know they live in new york
in these like
that's not real like that's a show
that's a tv show and that's not real and
so
you know just think logically most
people are not going to like set up this
like very perfect
scenario where my best friends from
different companies get together and we
pile up in a co-working space uh i don't
think so
so the other thing that i think is
definitely gonna happen is uh people are
gonna start building homes
with two offices right so like in
suburbia somewhere
it's gonna be like hey you know three
bedroom three bath two office
right right and they're not gonna just
be like um
you know when i was growing up you'd go
to like a friend's house and they would
basically call it like a home office but
it's more of like a
den so kind of like you know glass
little doors or whatever right
and uh you're just like wait a second
like that's not gonna be what this is
i'm talking about a full-on
office like maybe hooked up with some
sort of audio video capabilities
right uh and actually serve uh maybe
even be
sound proof to some degree like you can
just start to see
and it's gonna be promoted that way yes
i would add to that also i think
multi-family
real estate is going to look very
different so uh you know today where you
have these lobbies where people play
shuffleboard and there's like a you know
whatever like a movie room or some
amenity
like they're gonna just build co-working
spaces into every multi multi-condo
um apartment rental place because you're
gonna have all these people they're
gonna be in small apartments that
two people trying to work from home and
so a good differentiator will be to take
one or two floors of your building
and just build out we work inside and um
i know some people some places already
do this but that will become very much
the norm just like the way you're
talking about
the office thing like i'm selling my
condo right now in sf we took our second
bedroom
and we staged it as an office not as a
bedroom and like that would have been
crazy
you know three years ago but now it's
like made sense people want uh
a big spacious office with a good door
and good light um
more than they wanted a bedroom you want
to know my wildest idea when it comes to
the remote work and housing
hit me so uh malls absolutely getting
decimated
uh i think that somebody should go and
you have a lot of capital you have to be
super ambitious and you know kind of do
all the right things but
uh if you think of how the mall is
basically set up is
uh at the co at the ends and kind of in
the middle there's always the department
stores
right so you go in you buy mall with
huge acreage whatever
uh you turn the department stores into
uh essentially just apartments
right and then all of the
interconnectedness of the mall which
used to be retail stores
you basically build like a little
village and so you take like the
quote-unquote new york experience or
like the san francisco experience
and you pack it into like a mall
environment and then you use the
outsides you can either have some
parking or you can actually build like
walking paths and all kinds of crazy
stuff and what you're doing is you're
almost giving like the urban
type experience or like a college dorm
type experience
uh but i think that in the right city
done correctly would be
like incredibly attractive to people who
all want to work remotely
um and also then you get kind of this
bounce between work life and outdoor
experience into our experience all that
kind of stuff
right yeah totally and if somebody
resonates with that now's the time
because now
you'll get the you'll get a 70 million
dollar
um property you know for for 22 million
bucks right now
if you if you go try to buy up these
malls that are dying and all their
stores are dying and
all that it's either that or or they
become you know amazon distribution
warehouses like
it's gonna be one of the two like it's
gonna be an end point for e-commerce or
it's gonna be co-working with froyo
shops in between